alors attention
essaie tu peux me mettre debout
c'est le premier qu'il avait pour rester
comme ça jusqu'à 22h
les gars alors je vais vous dire si je
vous bats je vous aurais tous un gage si
je perds j'aurai un gage ok les chéris
pour l'instant attends attends
[Rires]
il y a trop d'eau
ah oui d'accord
ils sont cons comme des pendules
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
si je le mets on égale si je le mets pas
tu as gagné
les mecs ils ont ramené d'autres
bouteilles
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je comprends pas tu fais ça toute la
journée
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est le premier à Croix
[Applaudissements]
attention on va faire donc dans l'ordre
croissant une aiguille d'une montre et
croissant des déguisements c'est quoi ça
c'est quoi ça
j'ai compris ce que j'ai dit
[Rires]
d'une montre allez je vais faire les
preuves
de
Castaldi
les mecs la musique c'est le trou va
mettre une pièce dans le verre le
premier qui fait tomber le verre il a
perdu
[Rires]
pour moi je vous rappelle pour ceux qui
nous rejoignent c'est le fort Baba moi
contre les chroniqueurs si vous perdez
vous avez tous un gage si vous gagnez
j'ai un gage
il a pas besoin de savoir qui est Pierre
Paul et Jacques
il est malin
tu veux pas fermer ta gueule
tu seras tout seul
je sais pas pourquoi Benjamin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes pas très
les doigts dedans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il faut enlever tous les bâtonnets sur
le plateau celui qui enlève le dernier
perd la partie on peut retirer 1 2 ou 3
à chaque fois vous connaissez le
principe OK
c'est quoi le jeu en fait
[Musique]
[Rires]
toi aussi tu veux savoir compter tu vois
c'est trop long c'est trop long les gens
se plaignent
les gens se plaignent
c'est long chef
il y a cette musique
[Musique]
réfléchis
ça suffit
[Applaudissements]
non elle t'avait perdu à partir du
moment où j'avais pris les deux c'était
fini c'était fini pour toi je n'ai pas
voulu te le dire belle Benhaïm
chérie ça nous fait quoi ça nous fait
trois pour l'instant trois victoires
encore une fois ton atelier pour
l'instant les chroniqueurs vous avez
trois d'accord
sans faire tomber la tour celui qui fait
tous s'écouler père attention le jeu
peut durer extrêmement longtemps
je rappelle bois posé bois qualifié doit
homologué
c'est terminé attention
attention bois perdu bois dans le cucure
tu vas pas commencer à gueuler pour rien
dans l'autre sens je suis le maître du
temps
je le sens
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
vous êtes chiant
[Applaudissements]
je la sens pas
j'ai voulu après j'ai le jeu non non
merci vous êtes en situation
d'échecs
parce que moi j'ai aucune mémoire alors
c'est quoi c'est pour ça
il faut mémoriser la couleur des petites
boules s'il vous plaît Daniel c'est pour
toi mémoriser l'ordre et la couleur des
petites boules OK et ensuite reproduire
tout ça devant soi ensuite on découvre
le résultat boule par boule celui qui a
tout bon et qui est allé plus loin gagne
la combinaison elle s'afficher dans le
barco 10 secondes d'accord attention
c'est parti
j'ai arrêté le cinéma pour ça moi et tu
nous emmerdes
c'est terminé
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
on peut voir alors allons-y rouge
jaune mais voilà mais toi qu'est-ce que
tu as fait toi
si j'ai tout beau j'ai gagné allez vas-y
bleu bleu
rouge rouge
bleu
quelle mémoire est au nord et jaune
[Applaudissements]
je vais vous dire parce que on fait un
fou rire depuis ce matin avec les
équipes avec cette darka
[Applaudissements]
comment tu t'appelles mon chéri Jérôme
je vais t'offrir un très beau cadeau
est-ce que tu veux partir en weekend
avec tadule ciné volontiers ou même tout
seul et ça va le portable là c'est fini
c'est coupé
merci
[Applaudissements]